journée cruciale aujourd'hui au procès
de patrick dils ou les policiers qui ont
mené l enquête défilent à la barre et
disent leur conviction de la culpabilité
de patrick dils tentant ainsi de
justifier leur enquête valérie ermite et
raymond schaffler l'ex inspecteur
divisionnaire varlet et un homme
toujours très entouré
c'est lui qui a dirigé l'enquêté sur le
double meurtre de montigny aux
journalistes il répète à l'envi que
patrick dils n'a subi aucune pression
pour passer des aveux et qu'il est
forcément le seul coupable
on avait toujours aucun doute au jour
par
ne faut pas jusqu'à ma mort je n'ai pas
de doute il je pense que c'est patrice
l'auteur du meurtre
le monde parle enquête alors qu'il
voulait la partie concernant rôle ne
m'intéresse absolument pas des
certitudes
apparemment partagée par beaucoup des
policiers de la pj de metz très peur
hier soir l'enquêteur marchegay est venu
expliquer à la barre
pourquoi heaulme était innocent édiles
ce coupable un réquisitoire plus qu'une
des positions qui a fortement agacé les
magistrats et les avocats de toutes les
parties à sa sortie
l'enquêteur et plus peut déstabiliser je
n'ai rien à dire
c'est clair je pense que c'était un
témoignage partisans qu'il convient de
bannir c'est la raison pour laquelle les
parties civiles se sont élevées comme
l'avocat général et comme la défense
contre ce genre d'attitude on leur
demande d'expliquer préfets des
constatations et rien de plus ils se
battent une idée de bass et c'est lui le
coupable ça doit être le coupable
il faut que ça soit les femmes et puis
un raid en passant de ça peut ça doit il
faut et dont premier qu'il faut tordre
le cou un certain nombre d'éléments
techniques objectif pour y aller il y à
12 ans le témoignage des policiers les
aveux de patrick dils avait emporté la
conviction des url leurs dépositions et
le premier tournant de ce procès en
révision lundi prochain ce sera au tour
de francis heaulme de déposer le tueur
en série qui était tout près du lieu du
crime bénéficiera alors d'un statut
inédit à la fois témoin est forcément
suspect